[Applauso]
[Musica]
provate a pensare a quante uova avete
aperto nella vostra vita
forse 100 10.000 100.000 vi sarete
accorti della loro fragilità e tant'è
che a volte erano lì è un attimo dopo
che poi l'uovo anche un peccato
originale perché figlio della gallina
stereotipo di stupidità Ma io non voglio
parlarvi del cervello della gallina e
nel nostro e adesso ci arriviamo e sì
Perché l'uovo è il primo grande esempio
che la leggerezza sostiene la pesantezza
ma facciamo un piccolo esempio per chi
tra di voi Ne ha rotti proprio tanti e
ancora qualche dubbio a riguardo E
allora alzino la mano coloro che credono
che un uovo nonostante la sua leggerezza
possa sostenere un mattone un mattone
vero senza rompersi o fare una frittata
vediamo un po' anche su e c'è un account
ottimismo però in sala quindi esploriamo
allora prendo questo mattone è un
mattone vero
questo uovo non è di nessuno sponsor in
particolare di mia nonna o meglio della
sua gallina
e lo metto qui
nessuna crepa e nessuna frittata
le uova
sostengono i mattoni
i mattoni che rappresentano la
pesantezza ma anche la sostanza perché
con i mattoni si costruiscono le case
anche noi Siamo progettati per sostenere
i mattoni con le uova
Ebbene sì perché le neuroscienze hanno
dimostrato che abbiamo un sistema
neuronale deputato alla concentrazione
Vi presento il mattone lui si chiama
Central Executive network il centro
esecutivo centrale e ogni volta che ci
concentriamo ci focalizziamo siamo così
immersi in un'attività lui sta lavorando
c'è un piccolo problema perché se
diventa Iper concentrazione
Beh Noi siamo così concentrati che non
vediamo più le persone attorno a noi non
riusciamo a pensare il futuro e non
vediamo tutta una serie di altri stimoli
nell'ambiente siamo focalizzati solo
sull'obiettivo
Ma per fortuna abbiamo anche un altro
sistema un sistema un po' Bizzarro che
si attiva ogni volta che immaginate che
Sognate ad occhi aperti che pensate a
qualcosa vi lasciate trascinare dal
flusso delle vostre emozioni questo
sistema si chiama default Mode network
il circuito delle distrazione o del
cazzeggio Vi presento l'uovo
il neuropsichiatra strini pillai ha
dimostrato che quando i nostri due
circuiti lavorano insieme quindi un po'
ci concentriamo e un po' ci distraiamo
Beh Noi stiamo meglio abbiamo un miglior
sesso di benessere quindi concentrandosi
e poi distraendosi e di nuovo
concentrandosi riusciamo a risolvere i
problemi con una nuova rinnovata
creatività Ebbene sì perché quelle
connessioni neurali così forti quando
siamo concentrati nel momento in cui ci
distraiamo cambiano forma e si
ricollegano in modo totalmente diverso
questo fa sì che quando siete Di fronte
a un problema è proprio non ce n'è non
riuscite a risolverlo poi vi mettete a
fare altro magari ci dormite una notte e
la soluzione era lì e non le avevate
vista prima bene questo viene grazie al
circuito della distrazione
il circuito della distrazione e quel
bisogno del vostro cervello che vi dice
Ehi basta Fermati ora di fare una pausa
Fai qualcos'altro poi torna a
concentrarti meglio di prima ma quanto
diamo ascolto il nostro bisogno di
distrarci
e qui è interessante perché io non vi
sto parlando di quell'istinto che ci
porta ogni 9 minuti circa a sbloccare il
cellulare sotto coscienza e a consultare
WhatsApp Tik Tok Instagram LinkedIn o
altri social No sto parlando di quel
momento in cui sentite che è proprio il
momento di fare una pausa occuparvi di
altro magari fare una coccola al cane
una breve corsetta leggere un articolo
fare due chiacchiere con un amico o
magari leggere quella cosa che ci piace
tanto perderci in quel ricordo in
quell'emozione e poi tornare più
concentrati di prima
Certo che se stiamo 7 ore su Instagram o
Facebook probabilmente la nostra
dopamina sarà alle stelle così anche la
ricerca delle gratificazioni e dei like
però quello non è il bisogno di
distrazione di cui vi sto parlando
quello è un comportamento dannoso che
può provocare anche dipendenza e qui
quanto diamo ascolto il nostro bisogno
di distrazione Proviamo a vedere a cosa
serve anche questo circuito adesso
Facciamo un esperimento insieme Io vi
dirò una serie di aggettivi che
descrivono la persona alla vostra
persona voi Provate a immaginare quanto
Ognuno di questi aggettivi parli proprio
di voi sta descrivendo te nella tua
profondità oppure veramente molto
lontano
Allora inizio affascinante
abitudinaria
colta capace
dinamica
decisa
estroversa emotiva
solare
Timida e zelante
state pensando Quale aggettivo Vi è
arrivato di più quale magari di meno
magari vi sembra che descriva di più una
vostra amica un vostro amico ma non voi
bene in questo momento nei nostri
cervelli sta lavorando il circuito della
distrazione
Ebbene sì perché lui si attiva ogni
volta che Provata a pensare a come siete
fatti a quali caratteristiche avete a
come è fatta la vostra identità
e se ti va anche quando pensate a come
sono fatti gli altri a Come fare a
relazionarvi con loro quindi i circuiti
della distrazione e un circuito di
riconnessione con se stessi
di pensiero verso se stessi
Ma quanto tempo dedichiamo a questo
tempo vuoto distratto leggero invece di
stare spesso Concentrati focalizzati a
volte fino proprio all'esaurimento delle
nostre energie e vediamo un'altra
caratteristica di questo sistema perché
questo Vetto qua
c'entra qualcosa anche con
l'apprendimento
Ebbene sì Il tempo della distrazione È
un tempo di apprendimento devo
confessarvi che io non posso aspetto ce
l'avevo perché quando arrivo a casa la
sera e cerco di spiegare qualcosa a mio
figlio che ha 8 anni Alberto e magari la
mia giornata è stata molto mattone
inizio ad approfondire dilungarmi
spiegare un concetto complesso andando
nel dettaglio e io ho proprio la
sensazione che lui non mi senta non mi
ascolti pensa di essere totalmente
trasparente Allora sono anche un po'
frustrata Allora gli chiede ma Albi
Scusa ma hai sentito quello che ti ho
detto e io mi risponde andando a
delineare tutto quello che io gli ho
detto integrando altri approfondimenti
interpretazioni nuovi scenari Insomma mi
sorprendo perché l'immaginario Dentro di
lui ha creato veramente una fotografia
nuova e dico Caspita stava proprio
usando le antenne della distrazione
quella della concentrazione ha creato
qualcosa di veramente innovativo
completo
e nel mio lavoro anche io mi occupo di
formazione nelle aziende di leadership e
io mi ricordo che all'inizio dei corsi
si diceva Mi raccomando
non usate i cellulari vietati e
ovviamente qualcuno suonava sempre
adesso All'inizio dei training dico se
sentite il bisogno di distrarvi
ascoltatevi il vostro cervello vi sta
dicendo qualcosa di importante
E allora quando questo accade è andata
in fondo all'aula c'è un kit un baule il
baule della distrazione e Provate a
prendere gli oggetti che trovate
giocate con questi oggetti lasciatevi
travolgere dai loro colori suoni
portatelamente altrove Anzi Lasciatemi
portare altrove della vostra mente però
poi tornate qui
e raccontateci che cosa è cambiato dopo
esservi distratti dopo queste nuove
connessioni sinaptiche e in genere
emergono sempre interpretazioni
sorprendenti
quindi tempo della distrazione È un
tempo di apprendimento
e adesso tocca a tutti noi
dentro la borsa che vi è stata
consegnata all'inizio c'è una piccola
cartolina con un uovo Provate un po' a
cercarla c'è anche una matita
Eccola quello lì perfetto
ottimo anche su vedo che le uova stanno
stanno
emergendo Allora dopo aver preso l'uovo
e la matita questo uovo rappresenta la
prossima distrazione che volete inserire
quando siete tanto concentrati ma il
cervello vi sta dicendo di fare una
pausa
provate a pensare a quell'attività che
da domani volete fare ogni volta che vi
volete distrarre ma in modo consapevole
può essere un'attività diversa ma deve
avere un senso per voi ognuno avrà la
sua ve ne dico qualcuna uscire farò una
bella camminata oppure ascoltare quella
canzone che vi piace tanto
o magari per qualcuno di voi sarà quel
ricordo di quel momento così importante
o magari
due chiacchiere con un'amica o portare
fuori il cane e giocare un po' con lui
Provate a scegliere quella attività
distraente che vi ricaricherà di energia
potrebbe anche essere fare qualche
respirazione profonda e poi tornare a
focalizzati
vi vedo a scrivere
vi confesso la mia
che ascoltare una canzone dei Queen che
adoro che è Don't stop me now
Allora ci siamo
vediamo un po' come
come volge la nostra scelta della
distrazione adesso che abbiamo finito
alziamo le nostre cartoline della
distrazione
o che bello tutti distratti meraviglioso
quindi vuol dire che saremo più creativi
e apprenderemo di più anche sopra
sbirciate quelle dei vostri vicini
Guardate come si distraggono gli altri
e facciamo una bella frittata che
sostenga i mattoni della vita
e ogni volta
ogni volta che prendete in mano un uovo
chiedetevi Ho assunto la dose
giornaliera di leggerezza e di
distrazione per sostenere mattoni della
vita
[Applauso]
[Musica]